Trascrizione: Nicoletta Pedrana
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Vi siete mai chiesti
cosa sta dentro una tazza di tè?
Sostanzialmente, acqua.
Acqua nella quale vengono
disciolte delle foglie
essiccate in modo diversificato
per fare dei tè forti,
dei tè leggeri, dei tè di colore diverso.
Ma sostanzialmente, acqua.
Acqua che diventa un infuso:
e quindi una bevanda nobile,
altezzosa talvolta.
Ma anche una bevanda utilizzata
per momenti di convivialità,
per momenti di socialità.
Per dare il benvenuto,
per dare un arrivederci.
Molto spesso, in molti paesi del mondo
il tè è una bevanda identitaria
delle comunità locali.
Gli Iban rappresentano
una comunità indigena
che vive in un posto
lontanissimo da qui, nella Malesia.
E precisamente, nel Borneo della Malesia.
È una comunità che vive
all'interno della foresta pluviale:
un luogo difficile in cui vivere
per chi non è abituato,
per chi non c'è nato.
È una comunità che è abituata a vivere,
è stata abituata a vivere da nomade
fino a un centinaio di anni fa;
adesso è stanziale,
e vive all'interno di strutture abitative
che prendono il nome di Long House.
Sono delle case di legno
in cui all'interno si trovano
tante piccole unità abitative
per le famiglie della comunità,
legate insieme da un lungo corridoio,
che è il corridoio della socialità,
il corridoio della convivialità,
il corridoio del momento
in cui si condivide ciò
che è avvenuto nella giornata,
momento in cui, nel corridoio,
si condivide il tè.
E gli Iban sono agricoltori.
Sono stati a lungo nomadi nelle foreste
ed erano, tanti anni fa,
anche dei tagliatori di teste.
Seguivano questo rituale,
legato ad una sorta di sacralità
che oggi, fortunatamente, non seguono più.
Per quanto conservino ancora delle teste,
quasi con un ruolo scaramantico,
all'interno delle Long House:
difficilmente riconoscibili,
per la verità.
Vivono di agricoltura,
vivono di ciò che coltivano,
consumano, ciò che coltivano.
Prevalentemente, riso;
ma sono, anche, abilissimi
coltivatori di pepe.
Io mi ritrovavo lì
proprio perché loro coltivano il pepe
del presidio Slow Food,
il pepe di Ribas del presidio Slow Food.
Una coltivazione che nasce
per contrastare il dilagare
della deforestazione,
della foresta pluviale
e la diffusione sempre più spinta
della palma da olio.
Questa comunità è impegnata
a coltivare il pepe,
e lo fa con straordinaria capacità.
Del pepe conoscono tutto:
conoscono come si pianta, come si coltiva;
fanno questi allevamenti
su strutture permanenti
che durano moltissimi anni,
e sono davvero abili
anche nell'essiccazione;
per cui vivono dei momenti
di grande condivisione in questi campi
che mi affascinano moltissimo,
visto che è la prima volta
che mi ritrovo con questa comunità.
Noto però che concimano.
Concimano in una maniera
davvero inaspettata, inspiegabile.
E mi raccontano che il concime
glielo fornisce gratuitamente il governo.
Quindi hanno un concime,
un prodotto chimico di sintesi,
ricevuto gratis dal Governo.
E lo distribuiscono con una puntualità
quasi davvero inspiegabile,
perché non c'è bisogno.
Eppure, io soffro a vedere
questa distribuzione
di concime chimico di sintesi
realizzata in questo modo.
Perché i terreni sono in pendenza.
Perché queste pendenze
finiscono sui fiumi.
E i fiumi non rappresentano,
semplicemente,
una risorsa dell'ecosistema di per sé:
rappresentano una risorsa di sussistenza
per le comunità che vivono
nella foresta pluviale.
Ma intervenire con questi argomenti,
così un po' a gamba tesa,
all'interno di una comunità indigena,
e io che vengo da lontano -
è un po' complesso
perché rifiuto l'idea di avere l'approccio
di colui che viene da lontano
e vuole insegnare qualcosa.
E così soffro in parte
di questa esperienza,
perché da un lato vedo
un ecosistema straordinario,
vedo un posto ricco di biodiversità,
biodiversità animale, flora spontanea
veramente straordinaria,
anche per la relazione che ha saputo
instaurare con la comunità.
È una sofferenza perché, da un altro lato,
quella tecnologia invece
porta chimica di sintesi
che non può fare altro che portare
alla devastazione e alla desertificazione
che noi viviamo già da tanti anni
nei nostri ambienti,
nel mondo occidentale,
a causa di un modello agricolo-industriale
che ha devastato buona parte
del nostro mondo agricolo.
Arriva il giorno della partenza:
è un momento di gioia,
un momento di convivialità,
è un momento in cui
ci si riunisce tutti insieme
all'interno della Long House
per scambiarsi esperienze
e per scambiarsi racconti.
Io racconto della mia vita
e della mia vita di agronomo,
racconto delle mie esperienze
con Slow Food in giro per il mondo.
Racconto della mia famiglia,
perché so che raccontare
le storie della mia famiglia
rappresenta un modo per unire
il legame con questa comunità.
E nel momento in cui il capo del villaggio
si impegna a preparare il tè,
perché il tè è la bevanda
della convivialità,
è la bevanda del commiato,
la bevanda del saluto,
è un modo per abbracciare l'ospite.
E c'è questa preparazione del tè,
molto tradizionale
in cui il capo del villaggio
comincia a versare il tè
da una teiera all'altra,
proprio in attesa di raggiungere
la giusta diluizione,
la giusta concentrazione dell'infuso.
Il tè è una bevanda identitaria:
e quindi a lui tocca,
a lui spetta prepararla per l'ospite.
Il capo del villaggio versa il thé.
E in una tazza trasparente,
e fumante, me la porge.
Io rifiuto il tè.
Non è un semplice astenersi
dal bere, quella tazza di tè:
io scosto quella tazza di tè
verso il capo del villaggio.
Devo dirvi che, in un primo momento,
ho pensato al fatto
che loro in passato fossero
dei tagliatori di teste,
quindi ho detto: sarà
che la mia testa rimane qui.
Ma faccio un'azione che crea
il silenzio tombale nella comunità.
Arrivano 30 secondi di silenzio,
che durano un'eternità.
È vero che il tempo
ha sempre la stessa durata,
però sappiamo bene
che a seconda della tensione
e della dimensione che stiamo vivendo,
30 secondi possono anche
essere molto lunghi.
Al termine di quei 30 secondi,
in cui io vedo lo sguardo
del capo del villaggio
davvero provato da questa offesa,
io prendo la parola
senza che mi sia stata data,
e senza averla chiesta,
e gli dico:
Guarda, io rifiuto il tè
perché rifiuto l'idea di bere, nel tè,
i concimi del villaggio
che ti sta a monte.
Lui rimane un po' perplesso.
E io, dopo altri 30 secondi,
continuo con la mia spiegazione,
e gli racconto:
Vedi, tu ogni giorno distribuisci
i concimi nella tua terra,
ogni giorno piove nei tuoi campi.
Una pioggia breve, di durata, ma intensa.
Buona parte, la maggior parte,
la stragrande maggioranza dei concimi
che tu stai distribuendo
finiscono nel fiume.
Puoi essere fortunato
e finiscono nella falda,
quindi attraversano il suolo;
ma sempre nel fiume vanno a finire.
E allora, cosa stai facendo tu?
Cosa ti stanno portando a fare,
attraverso questa somministrazione
gratis di concimi?
Che sembra un modo per riscoprire
una rivoluzione verde
che da altre parti del mondo ha distrutto,
e sta distruggendo, il pianeta?
Perché?
Mi guarda, sempre molto offeso.
E mi chiede: Ma qual è l'alternativa?
Spiegare ad un capo di villaggio
cos'è una coltura di copertura,
cioè che esistono delle specie
che possono essere utilizzate
per coprire il suolo,
creare un manto erboso sul suolo,
delle specie in grado
di arricchire il suolo
di sostanza organica,
arricchire il suolo
di elementi minerali, naturalmente,
sembra un processo difficile;
invece, fatto con parole semplici,
sempre guardandosi negli occhi,
è stato molto molto semplice.
Il capo del villaggio, a quel punto,
mi guarda e mi dice:
Bene, vorrei a questo punto sapere:
sei disposto ad aiutarci?
A realizzare tutto ciò?
Devo dire che questi sono
quei momenti inattesi
in cui ci si rende conto
che si possono ottenere successi
significativi per la propria vita
e per il proprio modo di pensare,
di essere e di agire,
in momenti assolutamente non prevedibili.
Non mi sarei mai aspettato
quella domanda, dal capo del villaggio.
Chiaramente, dopo la mia risposta positiva
ho cercato di spiegargli, anche,
l'importanza della biodiversità locale,
di trovare specie
della biodiversità locale.
Ho cercato di spiegare il concetto
di vocazionalità ambientale,
il legame con il suo territorio,
la necessità di conservare l'ecosistema:
e lui, sempre più appassionato.
Perché vedete, io non ho offeso
il capo del villaggio
perché sta distruggendo l'ecosistema.
Per lui, l'offesa più grande
è stata quella di pensare
che non sta avendo a cuore,
quanto si dovrebbe, la sua comunità.
La salute della sua comunità.
Allora lì si rasserena la tensione,
si abbassa la tensione
e si comincia a discutere di futuro.
Si comincia a discutere
di un futuro che oggi è presente
perché oggi tutti i campi
del pepe di Rimbas,
del presidio Slow Food
sono gestiti senza concime
con colture di copertura.
Senza utilizzare più concimi di sintesi.
Allora, cosa mi ha insegnato questo?
Mi ha insegnato che una transizione
ecologica è possibile.
Che ritornare alle pratiche
di agroecologia,
dove l'agricoltura incontra l'ecologia,
dove l'ecosistema sta sempre al centro,
dove la conservazione
delle risorse naturali
deve venire prima
dell'interesse dell'uomo.
Di questa visione antropocentrica,
che ci sta portando
verso la distruzione del pianeta.
Ciò è possibile, ed è possibile
anche con una goccia nel mare,
nel Borneo Malese, un puntino
nella cartina del mondo.
E se è possibile lì,
può diventare contagioso,
può diventare estremamente ripetuto
in tantissime parti del mondo.
E se noi agiamo in modo responsabile,
possiamo aiutare le comunità
a sviluppare questi percorsi virtuosi.
Possiamo aiutare a raggiungere
l'obiettivo 12:
produzione e consumo responsabile.
Che poi hanno delle ricadute
sugli obiettivi 14 e 15:
Mare e terra, le risorse di mare,
le risorse di terra,
Tutto ricompreso in quell'ambiente,
in quel piccolo ecosistema
della comunità di Rimbass.
Tutto questo però non avviene
entrando a gamba tesa.
Tutto questo avviene dalla condivisione,
dalla capacità vicendevole
di instaurare rapporti,
dalla volontà di ascoltarsi
l'uno con l'altro,
dalla volontà di portare
informazioni utili per le comunità.
Tutto questo viene dalle relazioni.
E le relazioni, in quel giorno
si sono concluse
con il fatto che io ho bevuto
la tazza di tè.
Grazie.
(Applausi)